moscou les journalistes virait de la
chaîne de télévision ntv pour attitude
trop critique à l'égard de vladimir
poutine tente de trouver refuge sur une
chaîne locale ntv désormais aux mains du
groupe gazprom producteurs de gaz entre
autres dont le principal actionnaire est
l'état gazprom reprend les bonnes
vieilles méthodes soviétiques ses
employés bénéficient de tout du logement
jusqu'au loisirs illustration avec le
reportage à nadim non loin de la mer de
kara de nos correspondants 2000 d'eyrda
efron brisset il église tout neuf c'est
le dernier cadeau de gazprom à la ville
de nadim mais les fidèles longtemps
encore chanteront les louanges du bon
géant du gaz
le premier producteur mondial qui ici à
1500 km au nord-est de moscou est de
loin le premier employeur sur 40000
habitants 9200 travaillent directement
pour gazprom
l'hiver le thermomètre descend parfois
sous les moins 50 degrés mais si jamais
ils ne se plaignent ces hommes qui huit
jours durant brave la morsure du froid
avant de regagner pour une semaine de
repos la douce chaleur de leur foyer
c'est parce que chez gazprom les
salaires sont quatre à cinq fois
supérieur au salaire moyen
le boulot c'est le boulot comme dans la
marine de la volga
avant j'étais capitaine de bateau
maintenant je travaille ici une fois par
an ils partent vers le sud sur la terre
ferme comme ils disent gasprom au bord
de la mer noire possède son propre
village de vacances et toute l'année
finances écoles hôpitaux centres de
remise en forme et clubs de sport comme
celui ci l'équipe de hockey des gaziers
de pando dit eh ben c'est aussi d'aller
travailler progrès seront bien sûr oui
évidemment les nuits sont longues
non loin du cercle polaire heureusement
ce soir au palais de la culture
il y à dîner dansant
entrée gratuite dernier tube à la mode
bière et vodka volonté c'est gazprom qui
régale en dehors du travail ici il n'y a
vraiment rien à faire mule par et toi
qu'est ce qu'on en pense
oui oui c'est boulot dodo boulot dodo
c'est vrai mais ici on vit deux fois
mieux que n'importe où ailleurs en
russie et moi j'aimerais bien que dans
le reste du pays des autres villes aussi
bien que nous jadis à travers toute
l'union soviétique c'était l'état et le
parti qui prenait tout en charge le
travail les loisirs l'éducation la santé
nadim est une oasis dans le grand nord
et gazprom aujourd'hui comme un état
dans l'état